question one just ran it with me this is
what do we say page 20
so Hollywood's a makeup honey and sells
$1,350 the makeup that's a lot of makeup
or makeup is really expensive alright so
again just like we've been doing without
wage and salaries questions let's get
the important details down so $1,350
yes that's how much has been sold sorry
I still like it what it is anyway
um read on with me her Commission is 7%
of sales
saman right 7 percent commission okay so
it completely non visible payment and we
don't really get to finally enough that
she's burned this parts pretty simple is
nothing that complicates this right
because this Commission is a percentage
she earns of that the total sale all you
need to do is say well the earnings
remember of said before please they just
write like naked numbers that don't mean
anything like what I'm a referring to
say what your numbers are fitment the
earnings are 7 percent of the 1050 now
luckily for you you have calculators now
that have a percent bugs on them but my
day another percent and what you had to
do was you had to calculate we had to
determine 7 percent as a decimal or as a
fraction or any other kind of thing how
would you do that
what is 7 percent okay so you divide by
a hundred because that's what percent
like century it's what means okay so I'm
just gonna write for our sake you send
over Andrew times R 1 3 5 0 and once
you've got to this like but you know I'm
saying a wine of working right I think
the calculator can do
for us whatever we get 4.5 and of course
this is money so you don't be who talks
in half dollars right so I'm gonna go 50
Cent's by the way the editor question
press reports state that now say so yes
do the dollar sign on it okay so um my
show is that question is yes and like
I've said before right the big thing
about this course is that it's not just
about velvet the nuns are always
surrounded by some kind of context they
mean something right so therefore the
[ __ ] proof doll in there like I'm not
working I guess you're asking about
intervening fines up here yeah probably
not
as essential as long as it comes in you
yeah I kind of like to put it all the
way cuz like it is like it's not just
1315 as a number it's dollars it's not
also it's it's a way to help you do it
yeah
now question 13 just from looking at for
a second okay it's a bit of a mouthful
it's one of those paragraph question is
what's information in that you've got to
try to sort out that's why I want to do
it as an example okay so read with me
right it says Jenny was off a retainer
of six hundred forty dollars per month
so this is what we're talking up
okay so first input of detail let's
write that down
so she's going to be paid this
regardless of what kind of sales that
she makes 140 - she's got all these
extra things right now we've looked in
on previous exercise about allowances
and extra little bits of pain so you see
she's getting a car allowance so she's
obviously being asked to travel around
and her business is going to come back
okay
so nice 100 point $40 per month and
that's car allowance so I wait for just
putting the pieces together and then it
becomes the commission but one and a
half percent commission on that houses
your ever I sent you before one and a
half percent it doesn't sound like very
much but have a look now with me at what
kind of quantities of actual money she's
selling right if during her first month
apart for any company
she sold two units valued at and here's
some figures okay
so units and here are the numbers
we're looking at her total income for
the month okay so how are we going to
put all of this together right well
again what we're calculating is minute
so let's put that right at the front and
say okay well how we're gonna piece this
together now it's just for a month yeah
it's just a month so you see these
things which happen on a monthly basis
we can just put the right at the front
okay they're gonna get added in so I've
got the 640 and I've got the 140 and
then they're just sitting at the front
ready for me to evaluate then we think
had this guy so the one and a half
percent commission right so I'm not
gonna have no spaces I'm just gonna
fight on the next line but one not
percent we multiply that by however much
we sell right so we're gonna write it
one and a half cents and again like I
said you can't use the percent button or
you can just manually divide by a
hundred or as a third alternative you
could write that as a decimal and just
be careful with it make sure you
confidently convey to decimals because
people frequently my god decimals like
this especially at their heart take that
percentage and then I'm gonna call to
fly by the total amount that she sells
right so here comes the brackets and I'm
just gonna add those two things together
right that's the total amount the term
value that she has sold so to look like
this
that's it that was more complicated okay
and really just constructing this is
just to enable our calculator to do the
legwork
okay so I've written that in brackets I
could put on time say if I wanted to
kind of be quiet though what's your
ringing it down that's all the work and
you need to provide your calculator
community reps can we get a number
yep yeah so that that's gonna be yeah
all about it's all together flat so you
can see right
that's 640 plus 140 those allowances and
the retainer they were almost nothing
compared to how much she actually though
and that's the way occasions function
okay
that's achieved promotion like over
eight thousand dollars that they just
made up off in just this pot this is not
complicated think logically about the
pieces that you're putting here and then
combine them a creature like what these
numbers mean what we're gonna do with
the numbers you say there weren't any
questions something together do a check
what was real
okay now he's the right time to try to
work out what's going on cuz because
this looks good to me
no but it's worth mentioning like I'm so
glad because okay so which money now
let's just check if we're all looking at
the same numbers the only discrepancy
there could be isn't the way we've
inputted this right now just check
you've got your 640 be 140 at the front
you're adding these double check that
percentage what so you've done one point
five five percent over 100
that should be fine okay so you've got
to be a bit watchful here I guess
this is something which is coming up now
that one and a half is 1 point 5 divided
by a hundred the division my hope that's
all the percent button does
ok ok so consensus what's going on I'm
curious I want to know what actually
happens okay so so no on this buck right
pause so you must have done something
much bigger right like input okay
now actually I'm curious can you give me
the number I know it might seem selfish
giving it up
wait wait what no she means the second
time
what so we can take them the percent
buttons what did you get like the
astronomically large number what did you
get
hey can someone go yeah yeah yeah get it
from I okay excellent
alright yeah this is polis here okay
I deliberately audience discussion
because no it's okay when you see this
number you should not need someone
else's answer to be the prompt for you
that something has gone horribly wrong
so we call this and you probably heard
this phrase before we call this a sense
check right does it make sense
real estate agents right not bad for one
month's work so cleanly try to get the
magnet right its mobile we expect
question so that's what makes us go back
and analyze calculate isn't great they
are tools for doing those calculations
so we don't have to but they will do
exactly what you ask them to do exactly
right just be careful with how you